wenn jemand den schmollmund schwestern
edles oder teure schenkt gibt dafür ein
foto auf instagram klingt bizarr aber
ermöglicht den rhein ein leben im luxus
zu haben ein kommentar und dieser eine
kommentar ist hashtags platz genommen
es ist das jahr 2020 leute und wir sind
es heutzutage glaube ich alle einigen
dass man um in der alltäglichen welt die
wir heutzutage erleben überleben
okay noch mal es ist das jahr 2020 leute
wir sind glaube ich alle einig dass man
um in der heutigen welt überleben zu
können
markenklamotten braucht führende
experten in deutschland in der welt sind
sich da einig die herrschende meinung
ist mittlerweile angekommen dass man
nicht mehr für die sicherheit von leuten
garantieren kann die ohne gucci t shirt
aus dem haus gehen vollkommen klar leute
glaube ich und das ist jetzt die frage
wie komme ich persönlich an meine luxus
artikel dann gibt es gewisse leute
denken sich okay ich arbeite dafür so
ich hab meinen job ich bin angestellt
ich bin selbstständig ich arbeite normal
da gibt es wiederum andere die bilder
von sich verkaufen und davon leben
leute das wird alles beschrieben in dem
video sexy schwestern bieten save gegen
luxusartikel dass wir uns heute mal
anschauen und werfen jetzt mein blick
rein kein foto ole schmollmund und vor
allem kein foto ohne geschenk lucia
sophie und stacy brooks sind dies helfe
queens england ok alles gleich sich
schon das ist eine folge genau für mich
ich muss wirklich sagen wenn es eine
sache gibt in meinem leben die mich von
der qualität eines menschens überzeugt
und die dazu führt dass dieser mensch
mich beeindrucken kann dann ist es
definitiv dax gerade wenn es noch in so
einer wunderbaren formen wir hier
vorgetragen wird
also will er heute diese drei meditiert
ihre lebenswichtigen luxus artikel mit
saves bezahlen sind
queens superpopulär und mindestens
ebenso umstritten denn
[Musik]
ok ok ok wird sollte wenn ich noch
irgendwas weiter dazu sagen ich bin wie
kritisch zu den mädels äußere dann ist
diese ganze geschichte mit einem youtube
kanal hier vorbei alter die gar die sind
ja superpopulär superpopulär und einen
kommentar unter einem kommentar wenn
jemand den schmollmund schwestern edles
oder teure schenkt gibt es dafür ein
foto auf instagram klingt bizarr aber
ermöglicht den rhein ein leben im luxus
ok schwieriges thema für mich muss ich
sagen hatte ich habe im vorfeld für
dieses video mal die kommentare studiert
und die allermeisten leute sind gar
nicht so kritisch diese mädels
überdenken sie sich so ja okay wenn es
irgend jemanden zahlt meinetwegen
ich habe da irgendwie ein bisschen
größeres problem damit weil ich finde
leute marie talk an der stelle mit
einziges problem das wir in unseren
sozialen medien haben also youtube
instagram twitter ist gerade auf
instagram das einfach menschen die so
dumm sind zu vorbildern erhoben werden
und diese menschen sind einfach wirklich
dumm wie toastbrot glaubt mir da habe
ich schon so viele beispiele in
deutschland in der deutschen in foren
szenen erlebt es ist wirklich
geisteskrank und damit habe ich ein
kleines problem designer sonnenbrillen
handtaschen laptops an die dass ich es
schaffen mit 20 likes also soll ich
werde nicht helfen superpopulär sind sie
auf jeden fall super populäre das ist
schaffen mit 20 likes und wie viele von
euch die seite 967 follower haben die
tatsächlich super also die tatsache dass
man es schafft mit einem account der so
kleines nach heutigen maßstäben leute
dazu zu bringen dass sie einem
waschmaschinen kaufen
dafür haben sie sich schon wieder probst
verdient wir haben uns nie hingesetzt
und jedes pfund gezählt dass wir recht
und fein aber ich denke es kommt locker
für den wert von 100000 euro
ok muss los wo das ist nicht nur das
eine dass ihr wisst schon gesagt habe
auch wieder wie es viel zu oft geschieht
einfach menschen die nur gut aussehen
und sonst nichts können zu idolen
angehoben werde man auf einmal zu den
aufsatz das man halt aus dass es da
draußen männer gibt die die alternativ
finden und vielleicht irgendwie in
kontakt mit den geraten wollen und das
vielleicht als mittel sehen und mit
ihnen in kontakt zu kommen und dies dann
irgendwie so ja okay danke für die hand
das ist jetzt aber geblockt
menschenrechte sind superpopulär eigenes
geld schicke klamotten und schmuck
müssen sie nicht mehr ausgeben was
gefällt teilen sie ihren fans sofort
online mit und die kaufen es ihnen gerne
um die mädels darin zu sehen also das
ist echt zig leute so einerseits finde
ich es eben ja auch krass dass sie so
hardcore straight sind und falls sie
auch sagen so ja also ich kann die nicht
so gut einschätzen ich weiß nicht
studieren ob die was im kopf haben oder
nicht die kommen jetzt nicht so krass
wie wird man per se sagen jemand der
sich so gibt in der öffentlichkeit und
sowas macht er hat meistens nicht so
viel im kopf das ist dann wiederum schon
krass dass man sagen so jetzt mal eine
auszeit das einzige in dem ich irgendwie
so außerordentlich bin dann verkaufe ich
das heute wieder gegen luxus fertig
andererseits muss man wirklich sagen es
ist einfach so ein verhalten wenn man
eigentlich schwester das machen würde
als er wirklich so eine ansage machen
das erinnert sehr stark an ein ähnliches
geschäftsmodell das mit pro anfängt und
mit situation auf wörter und der masche
sind sie bekannt und umstritten als
abzocker also haben wir alles schon
gesehen
unter dem sehr populären in zügen bild
mit 20 6 stand ja hashtags platz zeigen
dass keiner dem beitrag ist ebenso
gelöscht hat also bearbeitet hatte die
gesagt wenn ihr jetzt so ein
fernsehbeitrag was macht ihr bitte diese
partie wieder rausnehmen
mittendrin steckt als es hieß wir
sollten uns einen ähnlichen job suchen
aber darüber können wir echt nur lachen
aber man muss bei der sache wirklich
sagen soll ich meine einerseits kann
jeder sein leben so frei selbst
gestalteten austria kann
seinem leben erstmal machen was er will
so aber andererseits stellt euch für
eure kleine schwester große schwester
oder wenn ihr keine habt vielleicht
cousine würde sowas machen was würdet
ihr der wohl raten denn alle drei haben
auch einen job die 29 jährige lucie etwa
ist als glamour model schon länger
erfolgreich
die argumentation ist aber auch gleich
klar habe ich einen job
ich habe einen richtigen job so ich
mache nicht nur selbst sondern das
machen auch andere leute mit großen
kameras bilder von mir
neben ihrer modelkarriere teilten sie
mit ihren schwestern noch einen seriösen
job
gemeinsam mit ihrer mutter sind die drei
inhaber dieses beautysalons und das
geschäft läuft gut und dient auch den
safe ibusiness ok alles daran ein
bisschen zurücknehmen scheinbar haben
wir auch mehr oder weniger guten job
haben ein kosmetikstudio mit ihrer
mutter zusammen aber war zurück zu dem
hauptthema nämlich dazu was man davon
halten soll wenn es schon war die
grösste stärke eines menschen ist gut
auszusehen ganz gerne kommentar hier und
zwar laut dieser kommentar du bist schön
aber dafür kannst du nichts mit der
sache eigentlich umgehen so schöne
menschen sind meist anzuschauen so aber
wenn es das dann auch schon wieder bei
denen dann keine ahnung sollte man die
sich nicht zum vorbild nehmen natürlich
sind wir nicht auf die geschenke
angewiesen
wir könnten uns alles selbst kaufen aber
ich wäre doch blöd wenn ich das geschenk
sollte das geben wir ja so krass zuwider
ich meinte nein das wäre so geisteskrank
bild von ihr alter stellt euch mal vor
sie würde sich nicht so zumindest leicht
auf instagram prostituierten in dem sie
eine materielle gegenleistungen dafür an
dass die sich halbnackt stelle ich mir
vor wie wildes nicht machen alter.de hat
das war so dumm von der einzig die mama
leidet vor allem wenn die 50-jährige
seines buchs die beschimpfungen in
zeitschriften und magazinen liest als
ich zum ersten mal diese kommentare in
der presse wahrgenommen habe war ich
geschockt man muss aber auch
andererseits sagen wollte ich kann mir
sehr gut von einem inneren auge
vorstellen wie so einige
sowieso war sie komplett auslassen das
hatte ich auch nicht gut man kann leute
auch nicht dafür beleidigen dass sie so
was machen aber es ist bei mir einfach
so und ich glaube das wird in meinem
leben auch immer so sein wenn ich leute
sehe die die tatsache dass sie attraktiv
sind ausnutzen indem sie die bewunderung
die andere menschen für ihre
attraktivität haben ausnutzen
der absturz und fragt sich nur was für
männer beschenkten sie fürs 11 wer zahlt
ernsthaft für ein foto für viele nicht
nachvollziehbar
arikan verständnis 11 ich hätte nämlich
auf der straße hätte ich auch gesagt ich
hätte die nicht wie beleidigt oder sich
einfach gesagt kommt hier noch klar nein
nämlich radikale die nennt mich
pessimistisch aber ich finde immer noch
was dahinter steht was diese männer
machen ist dass man versucht sich
irgendwie zuneigung und aufmerksamkeit
zu erkaufen
männer schenken den was und hoffen dass
sie dafür zu nehmen aufmerksamkeit von
ihnen bekommen und diese mädels spielen
damit und das ist einfach so das ist
einfach es ist das egal er findet die
aktion seiner frau okay immerhin
profitiert ja auch von der zweifelhaften
liebe ihre fans ich vermute dass diese
männer nicht viel echten kontakt haben
und genau das ist eben heute eben man
hier trifft wirklich genau auf den kopf
die sache ist die dass ist einfach so
viele männer da draußen gibt die einfach
so überhaupt keine chance bei frauen
überhaupt keine erfahrungen mit frauen
weil diese männer sind bereit fast alles
zu tun um irgendwie mal bestätigung von
der hübschen frau zu bekommen und dann
kommt diese 3er und nutzen diese
verzweiflung aus
kleine rohde ist jetzt meine meinung zu
diesem sachverhalt hier gehört wird das
hat mir gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare sieht das so wie ich sollte
daher kritisch gegenüber oder denkt euch
so wat sollen sie einfacher machen ich
bin sehr gespannt auf eure kommentare
leute ich habe euch hierzu weiter
schauen einfach vorstellungsvideo
verdeckt hier oben könnte main kanal
abonnieren das ist kostenlos und hilft
mir sehr und ansonsten wir da schon
rauskommen macht's gut
super
polier